Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between movie-theater food at
AMC and Odeon movie theaters
in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
It might seem like Odeon and
AMC are different chains.
However, they're actually
owned by the same company,
so let's compare.
Popcorn in a UK Odeon
cinema comes in four sizes.
There's a kids, regular,
medium, and large.
Classic popcorn at a US
AMC comes in three sizes,
small, regular, large,
and of course, if you want
to get a to-go option,
they have the AMC megabag.
Boom!
That's three times the
size of the standard large.
Harry: Let's weigh a large salted popcorn
in both countries to see
whose large is bigger.
So, our large salt popcorn is actually,
I think comes to 204 grams,
which is about 30 grams more
than we were supposed to get.
Joe: 194 grams of popcorn.
"Avatar." Haven't seen it.
And for my own morbid curiosity,
so, I'm going to weigh it in the bag.
I don't know, just
subtract, like, 2 grams.
How much could the bag weigh?
This.
620 grams.
Drinks at a US AMC theater
come in three sizes.
Small, 20 fluid ounces;
regular, 32 fluid ounces;
and a large "Avatar," 44 fluid ounces.
Harry: Now, shockingly,
our drinks in the UK
are actually just as big
as the US ones for once.
Cinemas I think are the
only place in the UK
where you can get a drink of this size.
The thought of getting one of
these from a fast-food place
in the UK is absolutely unheard of.
Let's measure out the
large in both countries
to see if we're getting as
much as we've been promised.
Joe: Wow, it's pretty close.
What was it supposed to be? 44?
By my calculations,
they've pretty much nailed
bang on the 40-ounce line,
so you're maybe not getting quite as much
as you were promised.
Admittedly, we did lose
a little bit in transit
and also a little splash
just on the table there,
so maybe you could round it up
generously to, like, 41, 42,
which, honestly, even
if it's slightly less
than you're being promised,
I think we can forgive them.
Certainly we can't fault
James Cameron for this.
Certainly we can't blame
the Na'vi of Pandora.
We also have ice drinks,
which are the iconic Tango ice blasts.
We have them in three sizes,
a regular, a medium, and a large.
Tango ice blasts are amazing.
They have a bit of a
cult following in the UK.
I think cinemagoers over here
really, really love these.
You can get them usually in two flavors,
which are red and blue.
I don't know exactly what
they're supposed to taste of.
It's kind of just tangy
food coloring anyway.
They're not supposed to look like this.
As you can probably tell,
these have just been sat out
under the studio lights for a while.
Here's what they're supposed to look like.
You can also get ice
beverages at the US AMC,
primarily in the form of an Icee,
and they come in three sizes normally,
but not the AMC we went to.
They only had regular.
It should be a small, 20-fluid-ounce.
The regular "Avatar: Way of the Water"
Na'vi-colored drink here
is a 32-fluid-ounce,
and of course the large
is a 44-fluid-ounce.
I think that's the exact same size
as the soft drinks we just had.
I would like to request,
I don't know how hard this is going to be,
if Yuelei and the rest of
the postproduction team
can make it look like I'm
in the underwater "Avatar."
With me just swimming
with the Na'vi? Right?
Whee, I'm in the movie!
How hard would that be?
Can you make it 3D as well?
That's pretty easy, right?
Can you have that done
by end of day Friday?
Yuelei: 4DX?
when I'm swimming around with Jake Sully.
Here is everything you'll
find at a UK Odeon cinema
that you won't find in an AMC.
Here's everything at a US AMC
you won't find at an Odeon.
We'll start with the
classic, which is popcorn.
In the UK, it comes in two
flavors, as salted or sweet.
You can also ask them to
mix them together for you.
Salt and sweet, excellent contrast.
You won't find butter popcorn
anywhere on the menu in the UK.
The fact that you guys are
putting melted butter on popcorn,
extremely weird to us. Stop doing that.
In the US, our popcorn
obviously comes plain or salted,
but we also have butter popcorn,
and yes, Harry,
we like to put melted
butter all over our popcorn.
Two things I want to know.
One, it's almost always referred to as
"butter-flavored topping,"
presumably because they
can't legally call it butter,
or maybe there's just other junk in there
and it isn't officially butter.
In America there's just some people
who are so nuts about the butter.
AMC now has something — I
don't know if this is to go
or you get this in the theater
— where they give you,
no joke, this thing of butter on the side
to take into the theater with you,
because there's so much
butter-flavor-topping drama in the US,
AMC was like, here, just take
this and go do it yourself.
Oh.
Wow, look at that. You
see that? You see that?
Oh, yeah.
I want you to pay attention.
Now, imagine I'm eating this in the dark.
"Ooh, I like my butter so much. Mwah."
Look at this! Look at my hands!
This is the messiest snack in the world.
I never get butter on my
popcorn. This is so gross.
Yeah, it doesn't actually
taste that much like butter.
It has a buttery flavor to it.
Yeah, it's definitely flavored butter.
That's not melted butter.
You can also get sweets
as a topping on your popcorn in the UK.
This comes in the form of
Cadbury's Dairy Milk buttons,
as Smarties, Kit Kats, and Rolos.
Speaking of popcorn,
you can also get cheddar
popcorn, which is,
I don't know if this is
just not in your theaters
or really popular in the UK at all,
but it's popcorn that is
tossed in cheese dust.
And also caramel corn, which is popcorn,
you guessed it,
encased in caramel.
[crunching]
There's a range of hot food
options at a UK Odeon cinema,
including the following:
Firstly, we have the
iconic cinema hot dog.
Now, obviously you guys
have hot dogs in America.
However, it's an exclusive
because ours is a pork sausage
while yours, I think, is beef.
That looks real sad.
Oh, no.
Oh, hot dog. Yay!
That's a pretty good-sized hot dog, right?
Movie-theater hot dogs for
some reason are really good.
You ever notice that? Movie
theaters and ball games,
that's where the hot
dog's the absolute best.
Next up, we have two pizza
options at UK Odeon cinemas.
You can get a cheese pizza
or a pepperoni pizza.
I haven't even opened them
and I'm losing my mind
because this is how they've been packaged
and presented to us.
What is that?
Um, I'm slightly at a loss for words.
I might be giving them
too much credit here.
I think maybe if this were
fresh out of the oven,
which obviously this is not,
it actually might be OK.
But there's a reason why pizza
boxes exist, for example.
Maybe look into that in future.
I'm just imagining any Italian viewers
watching this and just crying.
You can also get flatbread pizzas.
The AMC I went to did
not currently have them
because I went there
right when they opened.
They weren't ready yet.
But you can get also a
four-cheese, a pepperoni,
or a supreme flatbread pizza.
You can also get yourself curly fries.
Now we're talking. Curly fries, right?
Mm.
The Impossible nuggets.
[thudding]
Oh, yes.
For some reason I picked
the marinara. Let's do it.
Who doesn't want to eat
fake deep-fried meat
and dip it in a red sauce
in a pitch-dark theater?
Nope. Oh, wow.
Those are really bad.
We have pretzel bites at our AMC.
You can get them unsalted with cheese;
salted with cheese, which I got;
garlic Parmesan with cheese;
everything bagel with cheese;
and cinnamon sugar with icing.
They don't taste bad,
but they're really chewy.
You're going to want those
right out of the oven.
Or the microwave.
You can also get a
Bavarian legend pretzel.
The theater we went to did not have them
at the time of filming this.
At a UK Odeon, you can
get triple-dip nachos,
which are tortilla chips
which come with guacamole,
salsa, and I think a cheese sauce.
This is how it came.
What we have is just a bag
of plain tortilla chips
and a box labeled "dips."
We have the cheese sauce.
We have some very vibrant guacamole,
like someone blended up Shrek.
We have some tomato salsa.
Jalapeños.
I think this was onion
and chive dip, maybe.
I feel like I have to try
and assemble these somehow.
I want to do it in a way
that hopefully you guys can
join me along for the ride,
because it could be interesting.
I want to try and get some layerage going
on there if possible.
Oh, God.
Oh, no! [laughing]
OK. I thought that all
came out as one brick,
but there were actually two
pots in there. Thank God.
Go on.
Yeah, you go. Look at that queso.
OK, now we're going to
hit it with some salsa.
Personally, I think this
has gone sensationally well.
This is,
this is nachos right here.
Some people might say, "Harry,
do you want to heat these up?"
I'd say, "No. Doesn't need it.
Perfect the way they are."
Oh, man, look at the color on this.
No. My mum used to like the nachos.
She's not dead,
I just haven't been to the
cinema with her in a while.
[crew laughing]
Yeah? Yeah?
Leon: They actually don't look bad.
They don't look terrible, right?
Absolutely disgraceful.
I don't know what's going
on on that island of yours,
but your nachos, thumbs down.
I would say pretty
generous with the chips.
Not bad, right?
These are UK-level nachos right here.
I don't know who is
like, "Oh, yeah, perfect.
This is exactly what I think nachos are."
Did they make a mistake?
Am I looking at this right?
They gave us a thing of marinara sauce?
I'm assuming this marinara
was supposed to be salsa.
Can you imagine?
Because you just get this
and go to the theater,
and you're in the dark, and
you're watching a movie.
"Oh, man. Man, this salsa sure
isn't very chunky. Oh, well.
Man, I cannot wait to eat these nachos.
Oh, I'm so worried about the
tree of life, 'Avatar 2.'"
Oh, no, f---.
Like, what the hell?!
It's so bad it's, like,
oddly alluring.
Does that make sense?
This is terrible. I'm sorry.
I'm going to do everyone a
favor and throw this out.
Yuck!
Then we're on to the sides.
We have a couple of side options in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Unfortunately, one of them
we couldn't find today,
which are crisper fries,
which are kind of like
very thin slices of potato
which are fried.
However, we could get our
hands on these chicken strips,
which are actually pretty good.
Technically also included on
the sides menu are the dips,
so that includes basically
everything that you would
normally find on the nachos,
including the side of jalapeños,
the salsa dip, the cheese, the guacamole,
and this cream cheese,
garlic, and herb dip.
We have one prepackaged-popcorn option
if you don't fancy the
fresh stuff, which is this:
Butterkist toffee popcorn.
I think this is kind
of more similar to what
you guys might expect from
caramel corn in the US.
It's basically popcorn,
but with an actual coating
of this sugary, syrupy stuff.
Now, the AMC has a bunch of snack options
that you won't find in the UK,
starting with these, known
as "lifestyle snacks."
I'm assuming they're meant
to be a little bit healthier.
Starting all the way down here,
you have the Planters
sweet and salty trail mix.
Grass-fed beef jerky,
courtesy of Country Archer.
I don't know about this.
Rhythm organic white
cheddar cauliflower bites.
No, thanks.
Homefree chocolate chip cookies.
You got only 3 grams of sugar
for these smart and
sweet watermelon bites.
Mango sweet and tangy
supersnacks. Dried mangoes.
And SkinnyDipped dark chocolate almonds.
In addition to the popcorn,
we also have some sweets and chocolates,
which I will go through now.
Wine gums. Do you guys
have wine gums in the US?
I really like these. They're
a bit of an old-person sweet.
I still don't know exactly
why they're called wine gums,
because I don't think
they have wine in them.
On top of the gummies themselves,
they will have the name of
a wine kind of stamped on,
and they're different colors.
The flavors change according to the color.
Red one's always the best, of course.
Couple of Cadbury Dairy Milk options.
We have some Cadbury
caramel Dairy Milk nibbles,
Dairy Milk giant buttons,
Galaxy minstrels.
So, in the UK we have Dairy
Milk, which is owned by Cadbury,
and then the Mars
Corporation has their own
brand of milk chocolate,
which is called Galaxy.
And this is basically Galaxy chocolate
with a hard shell on the outside.
These honestly are really good.
Cadbury twirl bites.
It's Cadbury Dairy Milk
chocolate, and it's kind of got
this weird swirled texture on the inside,
so it lends itself to being quite a flaky
and almost melt-in-your-mouth
chocolate bar.
They're pretty good.
Aero peppermint bubbles.
It's got this weird aerated
texture in the middle,
which is designed basically
to melt in your mouth when you eat it.
Milkybar buttons! I
loved Milkybar as a kid.
It's basically white chocolate,
which I used to love when I was younger.
I think as my palate has kind of evolved
as I've gotten older,
I don't really tolerate white
chocolate like I used to,
but these are great. Bit
of a nostalgia factor.
And the last one we found
today was Maltesers.
I love a Malteser.
I still don't fully understand
what they are, to be honest.
What is the middle bit?
It's not honeycomb,
but it's got a crunchy,
almost honeycomb texture.
Now, it's not a prepackaged option,
but it is a sweet option.
We have pick and mix cups in the UK.
Pick and mix is a really
iconic British thing, I think.
It's basically this notion
of, you go into a sweet shop,
or in this case a cinema,
and they'll have lots of
different pots or tubs
of individual candies,
and you can go in with a scoop,
scoop a few, put them in,
and create your own mixture of them.
So if there's one particular
one that you love,
you can just have a cupful of that,
or you can go for some variety,
mix it up a little bit,
like we've done today.
The issue is when you're layering it,
you end up just going one
layer of thing at a time.
I haven't assembled this very well.
Couldn't get everything.
Just grabbed a bunch of stuff
that I thought looked pretty good.
Also I think some classics here.
Milk Duds.
Junior Mints, the big box.
Mini Snickers. Hey.
Skittles.
My teeth are already starting to hurt.
Butterfingers unwrapped minis.
And Sour Patch Kids.
And also Airhead extremes.
This, of course, just
the tip of the iceberg.
You can get so, so many candies at AMC.
This many.
You can also get a Ben
& Jerry's milkshake.
What they do is they let you choose
three scoops of ice cream of your choosing
and then pretty much
just blend them together
to create a milkshake.
Also in the US we have ice
cream you can't get in the UK.
You can get yourself a Dibs Crunch,
a Häagen-Dazs bar almond,
a Nestlé Toll House ice cream sandwich,
and a Nestlé's Drumstick.
The other soft-drink
exclusives are actually
aimed more at children.
We have some Fruit Shoots,
which come either as this one,
which is apple and black
currant, or as orange.
It's just kind of a bottle of squash.
And for the Americans who
might not know what squash is,
does cordial help at all?
You get a concentrated juice
and then dilute it with water
to produce basically this.
The main event as far as I'm concerned
when it comes to drinks are these ones,
which are the alcoholic options.
You can get alcohol at UK cinemas.
We got a few of the things on offer today,
and these include this Rekorderlig
strawberry and lime cider.
We have a bottle of Heineken beer.
We have some wine options.
Got a little bottle of red
here. It's really cute.
It's literally just like they've taken
a full-size bottle of red
and just squished it and scaled it down.
You can also get white wine
and I think rosé wine as well.
Or, if you're in a celebratory mood,
you can get a little bottle of prosecco.
Then we have some
premixed-cocktail options.
Today we got a classic G and T
and a Jack and Coke.
What about the beverages?
In the US, we have so, so many beverages,
starting with the Coke
Freestyle, the Freestyle machine.
You've seen it before.
It has all of these flavors.
I wasn't getting one of each.
You can also get a Gold
Peak unsweetened iced tea,
which they did not have,
a Gold Peak sweet tea, which
they also did not have,
and Minute Maid orange juice
and Minute Maid apple juice.
Chocolate milk, Dasani water, Smartwater,
and a Costa coffee.
They also didn't have that.
I could really go for some coffee.
I've been told that it is interesting
that we can get Costa coffee here.
It is actually a British coffee chain,
but it was bought by Coca-Cola in 2019
for almost £4 billion
and has now begun expanding into the US.
A large salted popcorn at a UK Odeon
contains the following:
863 calories;
48.37 grams of fat,
of which 37.84 grams are saturated;
92.18 grams of carbs,
of which 5.94 grams are sugars;
and an unknown amount of sodium.
Unfortunately, the website
didn't have the sodium information.
I did reach out via
the live-chat function,
and the guy said they didn't
know what had gone on.
He was going to look into it for me,
but I did not hear back.
A regular plain popcorn
popped in canola oil
is 550 calories, 24 grams of fat,
2 grams of saturated fat, 74 carbs,
1,380 milligrams of sodium.
The same size popcorn but this
time cooked in coconut oil,
540 calories, 24 grams of fat,
17 grams of saturated fat,
74 grams of carbs,
and 1,380 milligrams of sodium.
Now, there are no stats for
the butter-flavored topping,
which is a bit concerning,
but if you add butter and
salt to pretzel bites,
it adds 100 calories and 12 grams of fat,
7 grams of saturated fat,
and 300 milligrams of sodium.
Adding that same amount of butter
to this large "Avatar:
Way of the Water" popcorn,
which is cooked in canola oil,
you get 970 calories, 51 grams of fat,
10 grams of saturated fat —
[coughs] popcorn in my throat —
117 carbs, of which 1 gram is sugars,
and 2,450 milligrams of sodium.
Same exact size of popcorn
but this time cooked in coconut oil
and the butter topping from before.
That's 960 calories,
50 grams of total fat,
35 grams of saturated fat, 117 carbs,
of which 1 gram of that is sugars,
and the sodium, 2,450 milligrams.
People of the internet,
canola oil has slightly more calories
but way less saturated fat.
Huzzah.
A large sweet popcorn in the
UK contains the following:
1,790 calories; 73.08 grams of fat,
of which 55 grams are saturated;
253 grams of carbs, of which
84.04 grams are sugars;
and, again, an unknown amount of sodium.
Mm.
Gotta watch out for the
caramel corn, Yuelei.
This caramel corn in this size bucket,
1,620 calories. 64 grams of fat.
21 of those are saturated fat.
510 grams of carbs,
and of that, 404 of those grams are sugar,
and 3,190 milligrams of sodium.
Now, the large cheddar corn, seen here,
1,620 calories,
144 total grams of fat.
21 of those are saturated.
68 grams of carbs,
and 2,470 milligrams of sodium.
Yeesh.
What about the most calorific
thing on the UK menu?
Well, that would be a large sweet popcorn
with the topping option of
Dairy Milk giant buttons.
This combination would come
to a total of 2,004 calories,
85.08 grams of fat, 62.2
grams of saturated fat,
275.8 grams of carbs,
of which 106.44 grams are sugars.
That is just over 100%
of your daily calories,
109% of your daily fat,
311% of your daily saturates,
and 212% of your daily sugar.
Jeez.
In the US, our AMC menus vary.
I did find a PDF that had a
bunch of stuff listed on here.
I don't know how common it is at AMCs,
but it is the Bavarian legend pretzel
with the cheese cup and mustard.
That pretzel and mustard
and cheese total is
1,920 calories.
One thing I wanted to point out
is that it has 7,600 milligrams of sodium.
That is 330.4%
of your daily sodium intake.
Hey. Don't eat that pretzel.
Here I go.
Ready?
Are you kidding me?
OK, Yuelei is going to
try and land one in my mouth.
If she chips a tooth —
she's gonna have to pay for it.
Ready, go.
Bro.